اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم بعد اقتحامات متكرره من
قبل مجموعات من
اتنياهو يقرر منع دخول اليهود الى المسجد
الاقصى حتى نهايه شهر رمضان
يصف القرار بالخطا الفادح ويقول انه سيؤدي
الى مزيد من التصعيد وفي نابلس الجيش
الاسرائيلي يقتل فلسطينيين اثنين بزعم
اطلاق النار على موقع عسكري
الصين تشدد على ان تايوان جزء لا يتجزا من
اراضيها وان قضيه الجزيره شان داخلي
ترصد طائرات حربيه وسفنا صينيه في محيط
الجزيره وتقول انها مستعده للدفاع عن
نفسها امام تهديدات الصين بالحرب في
الاثناء اكد الاتحاد الاوروبي معارضته
بشده اي محاوله لتغيير الوضع القائم
باستخدام القوه
الامين العام للامم المتحده يدق ناقوس
الخطر ويحذر من تداعيات الجفاف والنزوح في
الصومال مؤكدا اثناء وصوله الى مقديشه على
ان البلاد تدفع ثمن تغير المناخي ووصفها
باكبر ضحيه لهذه الازمه العالميه داعيا
الى توفير دعم دولي كثيف لها لتجاوز
اوضاعها الانسانيه الصعبه
مجموعه عن باب الصينيه تطرح نموذجها
للذكاء الاصطناعي التوليدي وهو نسختها من
التكنولوجيا المستخدمه لتشغيل روبوت
الدردشه
مؤكده ان هذه التكنولوجيا ستدمج في جميع
تطبيقاتها في الاثناء اصدرت بيجين مسوده
قواعد تنظيميه مؤكده انه ينبغي على
المحتوى الناتج عن الذكاء الاصطناعي ان
يعكس القيم الاشتراكيه الى اللقاء